families are starting to prepare now for
the next school year applications for
ccsd
magnet schools they are now open and the
district is not letting the pandemic
stop them from connecting with potential
students
kate houston live outside leed academy
up in the northwest valley
with a workshop that's coming up for
parents hey good morning
good morning yes this is one of 40
magnet schools across the clark county
school district
and these programs range from
kindergarten through high school and
they can focus on
the arts stem and even world studies now
typically this time of year
magnet schools will be hosting shadow
days and interactive events
due to the pandemic these experiences
will be virtual
starting today now from 10 to 11 a.m
then from 5
30 to 6 30 pm parents can take part in a
magnet
101 workshop they can learn about the
application process
admission requirements and
transportation policies
you will need to rsvp for this at
magnet.ccsd.net
i spoke to gia moore the director of
college and career readiness and school
choice when applications first opened
she says ccsd plans to continue hosting
these virtual events
in the long run along with in person
the pandemic has posed a challenge i
think in all aspects of her life but
what we try to do with our magnet
schools is really try to leverage the
situation to be
creative and to look at ways that we can
create activities and opportunities for
our families
if you missed today's workshop there
will be three others including one in
spanish
you can see those dates on your screen
here all are from 10 to 11 a.m
and 5 30 to 6 30 p.m in addition to
these there
are two virtual choice fairs coming up
the fall choice fair is
this saturday from 10 to 12. the winter
choice fair is december 5th
from 10 to 12 as well at these events
families can speak directly to magnet
school
students and staff now a student can
pick up to three magnet schools and rank
them on their application
and that's due by january 5th of 2021.
reporting live from lead academy this
morning kate houston 8 news now
all right keith thank you very much it
is